this is one of the main battlegrounds of
weeks of protests over the fuel tax rise
that's enveloped the whole country
[Music]
cars and buildings burned shop smashed
and looted and some of the most iconic
monuments in Paris trashed
the number of injured keeps rising you
would have to be deaf not to hear the
wrath of the French people said the
Prime Minister and it seems the
government has heard the cries of the
yellow vests to some degree this
response suspending these tax measures
for six months no tax should put the
unity of the nation in danger these
concessions come even though just last
week President Ma Khan was adamant that
he wouldn't capitulate to the voice of
the street distinguish between fellow
citizens and their demands and thugs I
will not concede anything to those who
want destruction and disorder but now
the government has given in to some of
the demands of the protesters the yellow
vests have tasted blood and are now
hungry for more we won't settle for
crumbs
we want the whole baguette the protests
have come at a time when Mac Wong's
popularity has been sliding down a
slippery slope and hitting new all-time
lows when Matt Khan ascended office 18
months ago he promised massive reforms
from the pension system to the working
code and that he wouldn't relent from
getting the job done no matter how
unpopular it proved to be my reform
agenda is to modernize the country and
we will pursue this modernization agenda
Dipsy and any chance that you will back
down no chance his tenure as president
has already seen widespread protests but
until now he has largely ignored them
refusing to change course the
concessions being offered to the yellow
vests show that he's willing to drop his
uncompromising stance when it seems the
violence spirals out of control
Charlotte Dubinski RT para
member of the French National Assembly
Gilbert collar says six months is a very
convenient length of time to suspend the
fuel price hike soon if you don't he
went away money for C they are taking
the French people for fools they want to
gain some time to subdue the beast
before the European parliamentary
elections are held he says though they
think that the yellow vests won't see
that they're trying to gain time they
won't see in any case that the
government at risk of entering into
conflicts with the EU will be obliged to
recuperate the tax money they'll lose by
implementing the freezes it sounds like
they're mocking everybody it is in some
sense the same as telling us that we'll
be deceived and they're happy about it
we're talking about French democracy it
doesn't exist there is no Parliament
there is a disciplined authoritarian
majority that does whatever the
president says yellow vest protesters
are already being sentenced in court
with one man in the city of non-si
determined to appeal his guilty verdict
during a protest he streamed his
exchange with police live on social
media he says the video clearly shows he
did not commit the crimes he is accused
of here's his story
whether you suppose chicken
[Music]
prease Minh was saying I should be
detained they ordered me to turn around
so I did I didn't think they would beat
me I thought they would just push me
against the wall now you can see the
placement here he's beating me I was hit
twice in my ribs though I explained I
was just filming nothing else and was
there for just about 15 minutes one
policeman had his knees in my back the
other one held my legs down and the
third pinned my head to the ground with
his knee
[Music]
they didn't really allow me to speak
although they gave me a lawyer their
attitude to me was like I was already a
criminal like a robbed a store had tried
to explain everything but they preferred
to trust their colleagues and not a
regular citizen like me mr. Stanley is
accused of throwing rocks at police and
remaining in the crowd despite two
orders to leave his argument that he
couldn't have thrown the stones as he
was busy filming was dismissed as the
court ruled the facebook video contained
no verifiable date
[Music]
you